a familiar sight in Capetown these days
dug up trenches giant coils of cable and
more dug up trenches South Africa is
hungry for high-speed broadband internet
and fiber optic cables are the solution
so far the city of Cape Town has spent
over 600 million rand or around 40
million euros rolling out its municipal
fiber optic network after it's connected
municipal government facilities
businesses and private users should
follow explains councillor Sam their
limbic captain's vision is to ensure
that Cape Town becomes the most
digitally connected city on the African
continent and so we have a number of
initiatives that the city runs quite
aggressively the biggest initiative is
our broadband or optic fibre rollout
private companies are busy extending the
fibre optic network to the suburbs and
Internet service providers are racing to
deploy so-called fibre to the home to
private households David Ashdown
regional manager of link Africa is in
the middle of a fiber boom they employ
up to 1,000 workers on various sites
mostly in affluent neighborhoods but
they plan to expand to lower-income
areas as well but residents in less
affluent neighborhoods feel it's not
quite that simple apart from a lack of
success they suffer from high data costs
lower-income South Africans can spend up
to 20% of their entire income on just
one gigabyte of data that's way too much
says boozing toboni from the
organisation right-to-know campaign her
demand is clear we are calling on the
recommendations company like MTN Vodacom
so see to lower the cost of
communications but the most important
calls goes to a casa that as the
regulator they need to play a more
visible role in making sure that they
regulate when it comes to the cost of
communications until then full access to
high-speed internet remains a luxury in
South Africa unattainable for the
majority